There were hints that Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg were far from best buddies
even before a SpaceX rocket blew
up a Facebook satellite in 2016.
Facebook’s first satellite - Amos-6 - was supposed
to provide speedy internet to sub-Saharan Africa.
But the Falcon 9 rocket that was meant
to carry the satellite into space
exploded during a test on the
launchpad due to an anomaly.
It left Zuckerberg, who was already in Kenya,
with egg on his face. He said he was “deeply
disappointed” over the launch failure.
Musk addressed this publicly a couple of
years later, tweeting: it was his “...fault
for being an idiot”. And said he had offered
Facebook a free launch to make up for it.
The truth is they weren’t on the best of
terms even before the rocket exploded.
In 2014, Zuckerberg had invited Musk
to his home in Palo Alto for dinner.
They were joined by Facebook executives from
the company’s artificial intelligence lab.
It’s believed the Facebook contingent tried to
convince Musk he was wrong about AI being risky.
According to one of the dinner
guests, Musk reportedly said,
“I genuinely believe this is dangerous”.
He has repeatedly warned that
artificial intelligence could
one day outsmart humans as he
told tech journalist Kara Swisher.
As AI gets probably much smarter than humans,
the relative intelligence ratio is probably
similar to that between a person and a cat,
maybe bigger. I do think we need to be
very careful about the advancement of AI.
Musk believes artificial intelligence could
threaten our very existence, declaring it’s
“Potentially more dangerous than nuclear weapons”
Influential thinkers like the late Stephen
Hawking expressed similar concerns.
But Zuckerberg has a totally different
view of AI. He’s far more positive.
With AI especially, I'm really optimistic, I
think that people who are naysayers and kind of, try to
drum up these doomsday scenarios are — I just,
I don’t understand it. I think it’s really
negative and in some ways I actually
think it is pretty irresponsible.
That comment appeared to be a
direct shot at Musk who replied:
“His understanding of the subject is limited.”
So why do they have such different outlooks? The
answer can be found in the
products they’ve created.
Zuckerberg can’t be pessimistic as that
would suggest that computers are risky.
And that wouldn’t bode well for any
company that depends on the digital
world for its very existence.
Facebook has grabbed even more
of the social media market share by
purchasing Instagram and WhatsApp.
And its ambitions are growing.
In October, the Facebook company
rebranded as Meta.
Kind of like how Google became Alphabet.
A clear sign that it wants to be known
as more than a social networking service.
Meta is focused on building the metaverse: online
experiences projected into the physical world,
as Zuckerberg detailed during
Facebook’s annual Connect conference
And it has an incredibly
inspiring view of whatever
you find most beautiful.
During that conference, Facebook
teased a new virtual reality headset
codenamed “Project Cambria” that’s supposed
to be more higher-end than its Oculus Quest.
And its AI division is teaching
robots to feel things with their hands,
to learn more about the real world.
So, Zuckerberg’s personal brand depends on
the benefits of artificial intelligence.
On the other hand, Musk’s pessimism
is in line with his own interests.
If he believes AI-powered
robots are a threat to humanity,
then his aggressive push to
colonize Mars makes sense.
I cannot emphasize this enough. This
is the thing that we need to do.
Musk’s personal brand is
centered around saving humanity.
Whether it’s by building rockets
to the red planet or electric cars on Earth.
At the height of the COVID-19 pandemic,
Musk defied local lockdown orders and
re-opened Tesla’s factory in Fremont, California.
He called the restrictions fascist.
And even threatened to move his company’s
headquarters out of California to Texas or Nevada.
Which led to this response from Democratic
assemblywoman Lorena Gonzalez: F Elon Musk.
By the way, Tesla is moving its
headquarters to the Lonestar state.
Zuckerberg’s response to the
pandemic was the complete opposite.
He said he was concerned about
the country opening up too soon.
Facebook announced it would allow
all employees to work from home
permanently, even after the lockdown orders ended.
Of course, his company has benefited from
people staying home. The number of Facebook
users climbed ten percent compared
to the same time the year before.
Musk is likely not one of them.
He once shared this epic meme
linking the U.S. Capitol riots
in January to the social networking platform.
He also instructed his team to delete the Facebook
pages of SpaceX and Tesla in 2018 around
the time it was revealed that the personal
information of millions of Facebook users
was collected without their
consent by British consulting
firm Cambridge Analytica that used
the data for political purposes.
Musk said Facebook “gave him the willies”.
Zuckerberg had to testify in front of Congress
because of that scandal.
One of many privacy issues the company has faced.
Hackers breached the accounts of half
a billion Facebook users in 2019,
posting their names, phone numbers,
addresses, and emails online.
Recently, the company said it will no longer
use its facial recognition software that
automatically recognizes people in photos
and videos and suggests users tag them.
The reason given? Growing concerns over
how the information could be used.
Public scrutiny is something
Musk is no stranger to.
He appeared in court to address
shareholder accusations that Tesla
wasted billions buying SolarCity,
a company founded by his cousins.
Not to mention his trouble with the SEC for
his infamous tweets about taking Tesla private.
So there are similarities despite the
differences. One thing is certain:
both billionaires will remain
very much in the spotlight.
There’s a company in the spotlight
of another industry which brings
me to the sponsor of this video, Henson Shaving.
This razor was made in their family's machine shop
in Canada that built parts for
the International Space Station.
This expertise means the razor
has been incredibly engineered.
The blade only sticks out about
half the thickness of a human hair!
So there's less vibration of the blade,
giving you a much smoother shave.
It’s the razor I personally use. Because of
course, it’s not just men who need to shave
but women as well!
I used to use disposable razors but over 2
billion of them are thrown away each year.
I realized it made a lot more
sense to use a re-usable one.
Plus, if you use my discount code: NEWSTHINK,
you’ll get a pack of 100 blades for FREE.
That's the equivalent of 2-3 years of shaving.
Make sure to add the 100-pack to your
shopping cart before using my code.
The Henson razor ships all around the world.
If you'd like to try one out, you can
head to my custom link in the description.
And with the purchase, you'll also be supporting
the channel, and getting a well-made,
sustainable product which is perfect
for the holidays
if you wanted to gift one
to your family or your friends.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom